I don't know if this will get to you.
I hope so.
I can't go back in time
and fix all the mistakes I made.
But maybe I could leave something
for the future.
A legacy.
The world is on fire.
I decided to do something about it.
Hopes, dreams, ambitions.
The mission was to protect their world
and ours.
That's what we wanted Monarch to be.
Instead of chasing monsters.
If you come with me,
you'll know everything.
I promise.
welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
They just released a trailer
for the brand new Godzilla Monarch TV show
that's dropping later this year.
It's meant to tie
in with the Monsterverse movies,
so that's why there are so many crossover
characters.
Easter eggs during the episodes like,
what's going on with Godzilla?
What's going on with Kong,
the other Titans.
So we'll break it all down.
I'll Also be doing episode videos
when it releases.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get those.
The full title of the show is Monarch
Legacy of the Monsters
is going to be on Apple TV.
There's supposed to be ten episodes.
They say it's 10 hours long,
so I assume ten episodes.
it'll start November 17th.
Remember that
they actually just delayed it.
Godzilla and Kong, like the brand new
Godzilla X Kong movie too early next year.
So that new movie is meant to tie
in with this TV show.
that was why they were timing the TV show
to come out
around
the time that the movie was coming out.
Kind of like the way that Marvel does
with the Marvel Disney Plus series
that connect with the movies
the main character is played by Kurt
Russell and his real life son, Wyatt
Russell, who most people remember
from talking to Winter
Soldier as the new US agent character,
Kurt Russell, also in the Marvel
Universe playing Ego the Living Planet.
So it is funny
that they're reuniting in this.
I think this might be
one of the first times
they've been in such a huge production.
At the same time,
even though they're playing the exact
same character across different points
in his time. I like Wyatt.
Russell is playing the younger version
of the character.
Kurt Russell is playing the older version
of the character in present day.
they say the series is meant to cover
three different generations,
the first being in the 1950s
with the youngest version of the character
Wyatt Russell is playing.
then later around the time that Kong Skull
Island is happening in the 1970s
they say during the series in the present
day is supposed to be around
the time that the first Godzilla movie
is happening.
something winds up happening
with Godzilla's emergence that alerts
Kurt Russell's family to his activities
within Monarch.
And these are investigating things
and get involved with Monarch themselves.
but as the title implies,
it's mostly a monarch
based series with a bunch of the titans
crossing over into it.
Like they're delving deeper into the lore
behind the Monarch Organization.
that's
why you're seeing the brand new footage
of John Goodman's
random character from Kong, Skull Island.
The idea is that Anders Holm is playing
the younger version of the character.
I think the idea is that he's
meant to meet the younger version
of White Russell's character in the 1950s,
that they're both members of the Army
that get involved
with Monarch, that later in the 1970s
when they're older, they get involved
with Kong in the other titans.
it seems like the younger characters
find Randy's message in present day
after the Titans emerge
looking for Godzilla.
The other titans emerge during the events
of the first Godzilla movie
They get into a little bit of the history
behind the Monarch Organization.
They kind of teased it during
some of the different Monsterverse movies.
so, even though Kong Skull Island
is like the earliest movie
in the timeline that they've done
and that takes place in the 1970s,
this series will start in the 1950s.
I think the idea that Monarch is an
organization have been around long before
that and learned about the Titans long
before that and been investigated them.
so some event happens in the 1950s
and that's how White Russell's character
in Randall's young version, the character
get involved with Monarch to begin with.
We'll see which other titans
they wind up using on this series.
Like Mosley, they're focusing on
the Godzilla, but all the Kong of it all.
But there will be a bunch of other
titans as well.
they say the series is covering
three different generations.
I'm assuming that means Wyatt
Russell
is like young version of the character
his children around the events
of Kong Skull Island
and then his grandchildren in present day
when like the modern day, present day
monsterverse movies are happening
what they'll probably do
because this is coming out so close
to Godzilla X Kong or Godzilla and Kong,
however you want to call it that movie
is that there'll be some plot elements
I'll introduce that they'll cover in
future movies beyond Godzilla in Kong.
I think the idea is that right now
they're just doing this TV show.
They'll do multiple seasons,
but then eventually they might do
a future TV series just with other parts
of the Monsterverse universe.
they just dropped the first teaser
for Godzilla and Kong a little while ago.
The movie was delayed till next year
by a few months, but it's being released
pretty soon after this
first Monarch TV series comes out.
Godzilla, King Kong will be teaming up
in this one against the new villain
who they also teased in the trailer.
all explain who that is.
There are a lot of good theories like,
No, it's not like Kong.
That would be bull.
That's the Super Mario Brothers
movie. Like, Oh wow.
What are the other cons?
The biggest thing in this new trailer
is the actual team up confirming what
everyone assumed after Godzilla versus
Kong and then ending in the Hollow Earth.
Also, even though the title of the movie
was Godzilla versus Kong, essentially
they teamed up at the end of the movie
to defeat Mechagodzilla.
So they already started working together.
But it's not like they're super
best friends.
Like,
they kind of both went their separate ways
at the end of the movie, like,
okay, we're cool.
We're not going to try and kill
each other, a little tense between them.
It's kind of like Vin Diesel in the Rock.
Like,
you can't put them in the same room for
too long,
or they will start duking it out.
But there are other worse
people out there.
Thus, the idea
with this other new Titan villain
that they have to team up
to destroy the rest of the title though
Godzilla vs Kong The New Empire is
partially a reference to this new place,
the Hollow Earth did they just move Kong
to at the end of the last movie.
It's a new empire full
of all kinds of Titan history
that they've slowly started to explore
and reveal and Easter eggs and details
and all the monsterverse movies so far,
like they've only just started to do
Hollow Earth stuff
is where most of the Titans came from
and the ones that were from planet Earth.
They're a couple of titans in the
monsterverse They come from other planets.
I'll talk about them in a second.
but it's where all of Kong and Godzilla's
ancestors came from.
So when you see the bones
of other Godzilla creatures, other large
ape skulls, especially in the trailer too,
that's a reference to their ancestors
in the trailer, you see them tease
that other primate titan on the throne,
similar to Kong's ancient throne
in the hollow Earth, with the bones
of many titans in front of it,
as well as the bones of Kong in Godzilla.
Creatures.
but it's meant to be a reference
to this primate titan or its ancestors
killing the ancestors of Godzilla
and Kong before their ancestors
left the Hollow Earth.
Because you remember,
both of their ancestors
had been on the surface of the Earth
for a long time.
it's just an idea.
This whole cycle of dominance
inside the Hollow Earth.
It's been going on
since it became a thing, since the birth
of all titans that lived on planet Earth.
all the titans that live there
fighting to be king of all monsters.
But. During Godzilla King of monsters.
Even going back to the dawn of humanity,
we saw that Godzilla's
ancestors had been worshiped as gods.
Other titans had been worshiped by the
people of Earth on the surface as gods.
Kong's ancestors had moved to Skull Island
for a long time.
So there had been titans walking around
on the planet's surface for a long time.
we only saw some of the other titans
species inside the Hollow Earth, like
they just teased it during the last movie.
But we meet one of the other kings
of all the titans in the trailer here.
I think the whole idea
is that at some point
Kong's ancestors in Godzilla's ancestors
moved to the surface
sort of leaving this power vacuum like
we saw the Kong thrown in the whole Earth.
But it looks like it'd been vacant
for a long, long time.
Power abhors a vacuum, especially
when you're talking about titans.
So this other primate titan
or his ancestors probably seize control
of all the other titans down there.
and based on his reddish fur,
his blue eyes, super lanky arms, I'd say
this is a totally new orangutan titan
that isn't from the canon from
the previous monsterverse.
I couldn't find any history
on them doing an orangutan titan before
or even in the classic Toho films.
so I think
he's going to be totally original
and they're not jumping straight
to destroy
like which other titans in
the monsterverse would be powerful
enough to require Kong and Godzilla
to team out together to defeat them.
I think the idea now heading into Godzilla
X Kong is that monarch went down
into the Hollow Earth, set up a station
for research there and started to explore
more in Kong, moved in and because he's
one of the dominant titans,
he started to take more territory
and eventually he winds up
running into this other king level titan.
This is their apex level Titan.
and suddenly
it's like the Rock and Vin Diesel
running into each other at the gym, like,
dude, dude, what are you going to do?
kind of tease this whole grand history
of this ancient history for the Kong race.
In Godzilla's
race in the past couple of movies.
So I think we'll also learn more history
behind the Titans in the next one to.
but essentially
that makes this a Hollow Earth movie,
which I think we all predicted, like, Oh,
wow, this is giant explorable space here.
They just sort of tease
all these other huge Titan characters.
Of course, they want to do a movie
about those characters.
the ideas that they're building towards
another three way fight like we saw
at the end of Godzilla versus Kong,
where you have Godzilla and Kong
thrashing the hell out of this
new orangutan Titan
like they did with Mechagodzilla.
and they want
that fight to be interesting.
So I think that's why
they picked an orangutan
just based on its physical features.
The way that an orangutan would fight
giant gorilla titan in a titan
like Godzilla with their abilities.
you notice
how long the orangutans arms are.
It's not nearly as powerful is like
Kong is probably the strongest Titan
next to Godzilla.
But he's more of a brawler.
The orangutan Titan would be way quicker
in a way more agile, able to escape
or to keep Kong far enough away
so that it couldn't get him in a bear hug
in the whole idea with Godzilla is that
most of their attacks are area of effect
or ranged DPS like obviously tail
very powerful big tail swipes,
very sharp claws, very sharp teeth.
but it doesn't move that fast.
and its main attacks
like the atomic breath has a charge up
period in a cool down period.
So the orangutan would be able to dodge
it pretty easily like yet they'd be pretty
big slow in standstill in order
to get hit by Godzilla's atomic breath.
in Godzilla's area of effect,
attacks are mostly energy bases.
Fire form, for instance, fire area
of attack, very powerful, but has a longer
charge up period and requires
that it be near maximum radioactive charge
like it has to be full chunky Godzilla,
full of radioactive energy.
so they wanted to pick a Titan villain
that wouldn't
be super weak to their collective
mean attacks right off the bat.
But I think the whole idea here
is that if Godzilla doesn't
also move back to the Hollow Earth,
then Kong will become the new king
of titans inside the whole earth,
like the new king of the Hollow Earth.
While Godzilla is king of monsters
on the planet, Surface
the official synopsis that they released
just reads pitting the almighty Kong
in the fearsome
Godzilla against the colossal undiscovered
threat hidden
within our world in the hollow earth,
challenging their very existence
and our own.
The epic new film will delve further
into the histories of these titans.
Like we'll get more Titan history.
Like I said, Their origins in
the mysteries of Skull Island and beyond.
While uncovering the mythic battle
that helped forge
these extraordinary beings
and tied them to humankind forever
My early theory is that they'll uncover
the history of how Kong and Godzilla's
ancestors came to be worshiped by humanity
and came to be their protectors,
like they protected them from the more
dangerous titans like this orangutan race.
everyone post all your theories
about what's going on, the main villain
and what's going on
with Kong and Godzilla,
the other titans in the comments below,
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
So be sure to enable alerts
for my channels. You don't miss that.
Click here for my brand New Ahsoka
Anakin Skywalker
Episode 5 Trailer and click here
for all my Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!